l'Europe c'est le premier marché au
monde donc nous avons une force nous
avons une puissance
alors l'autonomie stratégique il faut
savoir ce que c'est l'automobile
stratégique c'est avoir son destin entre
les mains ne pas dépendre des autres
donc en fait pour tous les éléments sur
lesquels nos chaînes de valeur sont
dégradées sur lesquelles nous avons des
dépendances et bien il faut trouver une
solution d'autonomie stratégique alors
ça peut être la défense ça peut être
l'énergie faites l'industrie aussi on a
vu notamment pendant la crise du covid
que les médicaments étaient fabriqués
80% en Asie ou qui valait mieux
rapatrier ces éléments-là chez nous pour
qu'en cas de crise on puisse se soigner
des gens donc voilà il y a plein de
domaines comme ça sur lequel le Tommy
stratégique peut s'appliquer je serais
peut-être l'espace aussi puisque avec un
accès autonome l'espace et des vraies
satellites européens bien nous sommes
sûrs de notre destin et de pas dépendre
des technologies d'autres possibilités
alors la décarbonation un double intérêt
ça permet de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique mais également
de produire le calme et donc de réduire
nos importations d'énergie dans l'Union
européenne maintenant avec la
décarbonation on va pouvoir produire le
cale de l'éolien du soleil de
l'hydraulique de l'osmotique et d'autres
énergies notamment les énergies
hydroliennes bien nous allons réussir à
créer une nouvelle dynamique avec un
soutien financier européen et à ce prix
là on aura vraiment une énergie
décarbonée et en autonomie stratégie
européenne l'autonomie stratégique ça va
clairement passer par renforcer notre
production électrique à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne
donc on produit notre énergie chez nous
on développe beaucoup de partenariats
avec beaucoup de pays sur des petites
quantités donc là on n'est pas
indépendance et donc on peut renforcer
notre autonomie stratégique et atteindre
ce grand objectif qui est le Green Deal
en 2050 le pacte vert qui va nous
permettre d'être neutre en émission de
CO2 par rapport à 1990 et donc de
contribuer à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
merci l'Europe pour lutter contre le
référent climatique on est le premier
continent au monde à le faire
[Musique]